auriga weg gehen hallo leute ich es
wieder frei waren und das hier ist das
vierte video der geburtstagswoche auf
mal wann und da alle videos diese woche
zum thema geburtstag passen sollen habe
ich wieder mit einem schmeckt und die
ecke und zwar machen wir die
geburtstagstorte die fed für dornröschen
gemacht haben zu ihrem sechzehnten
geburtstag jetzt schon mal ein kleiner
spoiler es sollt ihr 16 geburtstag sein
es sind aber nur 14 kerzen auf dem coup
des nikon dabei auch nicht bis 16 10 und
falls ihr euch wundert warum ich so
aussehen wie ich aussehe ich wollte eine
fee darstellen ist mir richtig gut
gelungen sehr kuchen wird so unglaublich
schwer zu machen weil sie ja eigentlich
im normalen gucken will der aber total
zerfällt und vom besenstiel gehalten
will also lasst uns loslegen aber ich
sage euch jetzt schon das wird ein
riesen fehler weil ich bin nichts hält
kein kredit orten bauen ich hab mich
schon gewundert dass ich happy birthday
harry auf den anderen kuchen schreiben
konnte ohne komplette aber natürlich
können wir alles schaffen wenn wir nur
fest daran glaube es gibt sogar eine
szene in der die grüne fee den zutaten
das rezept zeigen ich habe versucht
daran zu suchen aber man kann wirklich
nichts mehr und nachdem die zutaten das
rezept gelesen haben machen sie sich
natürlich an die arbeit denn so läuft
der mutter hast du das rezept verstanden
na dann ran an die arbeit ja ich denke
so läuft das nur wenn man zauberkräfte
hat was passiert danach drei kaps links
ein schuss milch und das war's mehr
brauchst du für eine google mail ich
habe mir früher immer gewünscht dass ich
mir auch so ein kleid zaubern kann oder
dass ich den besen verzaubern kann dass
er alles putz ich denke wir fangen mit
dem man was uns gezeigt wird und bauen
darauf auf also kommt zuerst drei kaps
wählen unsere schüssel nummer zwei und
nummer 43 vanessa ich muss ehrlich
gestehen heute bin ich nicht aus dem
kopf da der hängt irgendwo den wolken
und es ja jetzt fliegen natürlich zweier
über die schüssel und machen sich selbst
rein vielleicht ab lag aber natürlich
kann ich das auch so
ich bin langsam echten profi und
natürlich ein guter schuss milch trinken
wo willst du und wir hören jetzt diese
zutaten zusammen und gucken was wir noch
hinzufügen dass denken ist dieser
grunert 14 stockwerke ich weiß nicht wie
ich mit 3 1 und 3 cups mail 14
stockwerke backen soll unter dem
blumenkranz für die wieder aus dem wieso
nur hausfrau aus den fünfzigern wir
leben in der vorstadt in einem kleinen
haus mit garten und haben in golden
betrieb es wird langsam ein teig aber
ein gucken ist kein kuchen ohne sogar
[Musik]
zauberei für debatten ohne rezept macht
eigentlich am meisten spaß weil es ist
wie in so einem alten computer spiel
gute zutaten reindrücken konntest du
gucken konnte ist was dabei rauskommen
um den gucken auch häufig zu kriegen den
wir natürlich backpulver eine halbe tüte
durch das mit der hand reichlich voll
die starken arme länder der eu
debattiert oder das ist der falsche für
david ferrer mit dornröschen im wald
leben dachte ich dass man hatte müsse
noch dazu packen kann denn im wald gibt
es viele haselnüsse wir machen mal 100
gramm sehr schöner teil habe ich
irgendwas vergessen
mutter ich möchte mal ganz kurz die
butter und pax sie dazu trick 17 wenn
ihr beim kochen kann man genauso wie
hunger bekommt wie ich eine gurke unsere
mutter ist jetzt flüssig und kommt in
den teig schön die butter einrühren
verrate euch jetzt meinen plan ich werde
den teig in machen vom rhein kippen
damit wir einen schönen großen kugel
kind kriegen und nicht so viele kuchen
backen müssen das sind 14 stockwerke das
würde niemals hinhauen mit einer
normalen größe deswegen machen vor schön
einfetten die dinger nicht mehr extra
kein machen papier weil man hier sonst
auf dem kuchen diese form sehen würde
und die wollen und jetzt nehmt ihr euch
einen
und füllt die in die frau aber macht
nicht zu viel und die kann jetzt bei 180
grad für ungefähr 40 minuten in den
backofen also ich nehme sie raus wenn
sie fertig aussehen
italien derzeit in derivate könnt ihr
eure gruppe auch essen und wir können
die buttercreme schon vorbereitet diese
künstlichen wimpern machen mich fix und
alle
die halten dass die mädels aus und sein
letztes mal sind wir schon kleine profis
mit der buttercreme ich muss natürlich
nicht noch mal lesen wie das
funktioniert und so betriebe brauchen
wir natürlich 250 gramm von unserer
buttercreme fertigmischung aber die war
wirklich gut ohne witz die creme hat so
lecker geschmeckt das kann ich wirklich
empfehlen due.de water ihnen geboren ist
natürlich nicht unten den paypal in der
video beschreibung mit geldspenden wollt
die profis unter euch wissen dass das
jetzt eine stunde ruhen muss und der
kuchen muss er noch abkühlen das heißt
wir sehen uns in einer stunde wieder so
unserem affen sind abgekühlt und ich
habe den kopf schon abgeschnitten
wow das ist ein richtig guter kuchenteig
wir fragen jetzt ganz viele kleine chor
und der teig noch übrig war habe ich für
kleine mini chrome verwendet
hallo ich bin ganz kleiner machen jetzt
auch unser silikon masse fest und wir
können butter steif schlagen weiß es ist
ihnen aber ist auch mein format also
meine regeln
und wenn eure butter so richtig schön
schaurig ist's dann macht mir was von
der spachtelmasse rein
es ist mittlerweile schon wieder 17 uhr
ich brauche einen kaffee unserem
buttercreme es jetzt endlich fertig
gemixt jetzt müssen wir sie im zwei drei
teile aufteilen denn wir brauchen einmal
gelb so ein quatsch blau und so ein
etwas dunkles blau ob wir das hinkriegen
ist eine andere frage eine messerspitze
and what happens zu seebad leute ich
habe es geschafft habe das dunkle blau
die partie ist aber das hellblau und
ganz crazy gehe jetzt müssen wir unsere
muffins auf stapeln und sieben ihr das
mache ich aber hier mit euch
es tut mir leid dass jetzt nicht mehr
mein wunderschönes gesicht sehen werdet
aber es ist gerade echt wichtiger was
ich hier tue jetzt versuche ich die
creme dran zu machen sondern es läuft da
so runter also versuchen wir das auch so
zu machen als ob es da runter laufen
wird und so macht ihr das jetzt mit
allen muffins bis ihr den turm buch habt
jetzt befördert umfeld stecke ich einen
strohhalm rein um ihn zu befestigen
hab ich mir irgendwie da wird unser
komisches gerüst jetzt nicht runterfällt
basteln wir unseren b
jetzt ist einstieg ein bisschen zucker
wird schmeckt eigentlich reichen doch
nach sogar mal mein lieblings teilweise
kuchen haben uns ganz viel hall von dort
nach hause gemacht kann jetzt all die
coolen sachen damit ich nehme zum fertig
stäbchen und da wirklich den von rom ich
muss das von dornach braun machen
das sind es richtig aus die holzmaserung
ich bin eine geborene beckeln bäckerin
bäckermeister wir einmal den fakt dass
der komischen wieder um
uns erwartet ein besenstiel das ist der
besenstiel natürlich mal dran so der
oberste hat oben eine helle creme
jetzt kommen die gelbe verzierung von
der ich sehr viel angst haben
[Musik]
man bleibt mal schön aufrecht dort
schaut euch diesen scheiß kuchener und
hier ist so kacke geworden
[Musik]
okay das ist ja ich muss jetzt meine
kerze noch bevor irgendwas passiert muss
ich den ersten kann ich dir noch stehen
lassen nicht ich mache mal
stellvertretend für den kuchen probiere
ich jetzt teig mit buttercreme schon
lecker und mir ist aufgefallen dass ich
echt gerne von du also wenn euch diese
folge wie schmeckt gefallen hat dann
hinterlasst mir einen daumen nach oben
und schreibt mir rezeptvorschlägen in
die kommentare aus film und serien was
ihr nach gekocht haben wollt bitte keine
komischen torten die einfach zu krass
sind schaut euch die an die iss zu gras
ich muss aber auch sagen ich bin
mittlerweile echt ein bisschen kaputt
also sieben videos ist schon eine ganz
schöne herausforderung ansonsten sehen
wir uns dann wollen beim nächsten video
wieder biss dann das alter